في الاثناء اتهم رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو بالسعي
للاستيلاء على السلطه وفي مقابله مع صحيفه
فينانشي البريطانيه اتهم البرهان ايضا
قوات الدعم السريع بقتل موظفين من برنامج
الغذاء العالمي ومهاجمه قافله تابعه
للسفاره الامريكيه
كما حمل البرهان قوات الدعم السريع
المسؤوليه عن اعمال نهب الواسعه النطاق في
الخرطوم ومنطقه دارفور
واشار الى ان جزءا كبيرا من قوات الدعم
السريع خرج عن السيطره وفق تعبيره
البرهان اتهم ايضا قائد قوات الدعم السريع
باشعار ازمه دبلوماسيه باختطافه جنودا
مصريين موجودين في السودان في مهمه رسميه
وفي الشان الميداني اكد البرهان ان مطار
الخرطوم ليس تحت سيطره اي من الطرفين حتى
الان
من جهه ثانيه قال البرهان ان الشعب
السوداني دعم الجيش في مواجهه قوات الدعم
السريع وانه بمجرد هزيمه حميتي يمكن
استئناف عمليه الانتقال الديمقراطي في
البلاد
واكد البرهان على التزام الجيش باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه بموجب الاتفاق الاطري
ونقل السلطه الى حكومه يقودها مدني
وفي مقابله مع صحيفه ايضا قال قائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان ان الدعم السريع
مستعد لوقف القتال لكن البرهان غير مستعد
لذلك
واكد انه لم يعارض من حيث المبدا دم قوات
الدعم السريع الى القوات النظاميه المسلحه
واتهم حمايه البرهان بالمسؤوليه عن نشر
الخوف بين المواطنين والدبلوماسيين في
السودان
وفي الشان الميداني قال حميدتين قوات
البرهان تتمتع بميزه القوه الجويه
بالاضافه الى المدفعيه الثقيله لكن
الطرفين متساويان في ساحه المعركه كذلك
نفى حمايه تما وصفها بالتكهنات الغربيه
باحتمال مشاركه مقاتل فاغنر في القتال الى
جانب قوات الدعم السريعه